nobody likes a slow internet connection
but how do you know that you've got the
best one the fastest one especially
with so many more people working from
home and home schooling well kirsten
joyce joining us now with some ways to
boost your wi-fi signal kirsten denise
now that many of us are working from
home and have kids attending school from
home
you might notice your wi-fi has
seriously slowed down well you can make
it as robust as possible with some
simple tips
and add-on gadgets yeah just click
around there okay
when the pandemic hit jimmy and alfons
watrowski started working their
full-time jobs from home we're lucky
enough
very grateful to have kept them carving
out personal spaces for
everyone became challenging when both
daughters then began
distance learning we've got a kid in the
kitchen a kid in her bedroom husband's
in the kitchen i'm in
literally a playroom surrounded by legos
four people on devices can take a toll
the biggest issue we saw was more just
with our isp
like our internet would go out
occasionally there's a lot of
zooms with total strangers that
potentially held my future in their
hands
where when the internet would be slow
five minutes before we would start i
would be like should i just do it on my
phone should we you know where is a hot
spot
i'm gonna go to starbucks to give your
wi-fi a boost start with your internet
service provider probably loans you a
router
call the company to make sure your
router is up to date if not you can
usually exchange your old one for the
latest version
while you're on the phone with your
provider look into upgrading your plan
as the one you committed to years ago
might no longer support
all the devices right now now back to
that router where you place it is key
place it on the same floor of the home
where everyone will be using their
devices
and consider putting it high up on a
shelf instead of tucked away in a low
cabinet
if your house has some dead zones many
levels or far-off workspaces
consider getting a wi-fi extender to
bounce your signal a bit further
and if that's not quite enough invest in
a mesh network to create more routers
within your home
the watrowski family had some of the
equipment replaced outside their house
to help stabilize the internet within
and they beefed up their wi-fi
equivalent to that of a small business
it gives us a great wi-fi coverage and
like speeds throughout the house
work and education from home is moving
smoothly so nicely in fact this family
isn't anxious to get things back to
pre-pandemic levels just yet
it's been really great i know that it
seems weird to say but i might
i feel i'll miss it probably no i won't
miss
covid and the drama and the tragedy of
everything but i will miss
i see my kids all day that's pretty cool
and here is one last tip consider
plugging yourself in with an ethernet
cable
or through an inexpensive adapter
they're cheap they
will free up the wi-fi for other users
and will guarantee a good
internet connection 8 news now we'll be
right back